ça a commencé avec une confiance j'avais
environ 21 ans avec lui que j'ai
enregistré mon premier vinyle avec le
succès au coût d'un oeil au yo yo yo yo
volatils cov continent au yo yo yo yo
vatican petit innocent c'est un don
c'est en 71 je chantais avec ma soeur
uzi even as un beau succès et sa manche
et la carrière s'est poursuivie
intérieur partagé parce que vous vous
étiez enseignants oui j'étais enseignant
j'ai enseigné les mathématiques et la
musique et j'avais l'occasion justement
de constater qu' il y avait vraiment une
méconnaissance des rythmes antillais
puis les enfants c'est pourquoi ça va
permis de composer une chanson qui
s'appelle pushing un que je peux
la jeunesse paya a oublié big'in la
bassée lamazou
[Musique]
cooking mama y l'école numérique rien
oublié photo roman mais là ça a été
d'abord la rencontre avec le père elie
qui m'a permis de travailler de poser ma
voix par emilie a fait l'école de naples
je suis parti en tout lien avec lui avec
l'acura les îles du vent il a beau
chantier lefa but en or n aurait qu on
sent qu'un crier jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
étudié c'est vraiment un tueur de la
noël
alors après après le père elie j'ai fait
la connaissance de deux grands du grand
maître fernand de l'acien je fais partie
de ceux nos caisses avec lui j'ai
enregistré justement une chanson qui
traite les très belles aussi d'ailleurs
qui s'appelle les coups 3 francs 1 6 1
qui pour toi fra - peine il avait besoin
mais là sont moins cool et serait en
revoyant que pousser et la chose que
j'ai eu c'est que donne au quart d'heure
il y avait le grand pour leur usine
j'ai partagé justement beaucoup de
moments avec lui ben accompagne au piano
il y avait laurent marode c'est une
grande gueule période et fernand
donatien c'est je vais dire en quelque
sorte c'est lui qui m'inspire j'ai
toutes mes chances au m'a permis de
composer des biguines mazurkas le grand
frère d'un audacieux
alors après cela j'ai voulu donc voler
de mes propres ailes et il ya eu des
événements le post critique qui ont
marqué ma vie j'ai fait la rencontre
spirituelle parce que j'ai eu une
période très difficile et c'est dieu
le grand maître donc c'est pourquoi
j'avais commencé donc le spectacle de
mer du samedi ce samedi 11 par une
grande partie spirituelle à la gloire de
dieu avec de très beaux chants de très
belles musiques de très belles mélodies
de très beaux chants et donc cette
deuxième partie que jouerie je vais
rendre hommage à mes parents qui vont
donner le goût des belles mélodies et je
vais interpréter des chansons
particulier quand c'est celle là par
exemple que tu arrives la chanson maria
ho
je vois c'est prend qu'il y aura des
étoiles sous la voûte les siens
il y aura dans la nuit son voile a dit
boehner poulet